大家好 今天是2015年6月714年5月12日 今天算是一堂克补
是價值論的一個部分 今天的題目是價值回歸於君之回歸
好 我們3年公共準時開始 我是賺賣最近小號又被驚嚴了 所以我講課 略爲僅審議是大家也在平台上發言
好 今天是25年6月7日14年5月12日 今天是價值論克补 題目是價值回歸於君之回歸
我們計算是一個課部 也算是聊天吧 這個放鬆一點
我最近這個時間再給大家準備夢準備的過程中了 我其實是非常崗台的
準確的講其實我在安排這個課的時候 我在安排這個課的時候 我其實也是有一點點的呼吸
因為我在重新的安排我的驚嚴社會主義通論的時候 涉及到的歷史的部分 我是從夢子講起的
所以我將夢子定義為中國的古典的普速的社會主義者 而整部夢子裡面所提出來的重要的思想 構成了我國這個古典的普速的社會主義思想
在思考中國哲學史或者思想史的時候 這是一個非常重要的過程
我一直同意為跟思坦的看法 就是為跟思坦說 語言即使信息傳導的工具
也是認知的翻理就是歷史大約沒語言 那是傳導的工具信息
我只是傳導的工具 都是他也是主黨人們認知的翻理或者是想把它語言是一個具有非常兩面性的東西
我在說什麼呢 我在說 隨時中國的古典 古文或者是古典的東西都在哪裡
但隨著實在的變間 特別是走入近代以來當我們重新回看古典的時候 我們有的時候會可能也是一種需要的
特別是二十世紀 中國的一大批的輔導者 意圖用西方的已經形成的
羅紀 或者是語言 或者是方法來解購中國的古典 古代的一些重要的思想
在整個的解購過程中 出現了嚴重的天差和書 其實我在講問你的時候
我這還多少呢 放了十幾種版本的 香港的多少 大概也是有類似這麼多
我都及了台灣的香港的和國內的 香港年的比較全美的書籍
總體上我是感到非常失望的 還有意思的是 昨天6月6日在深圳開這個全世界的汗血大會
又涉及到中國的四十五進 二十幾到中國的古典的思想和古典的哲學的再學時的問題
星期四 我跟一個北京的朋友 阿通的一個一個小時的電話 我就不說他的名字了
他是北大讀文學史的博士 把現在分析這個 出版編輯工作
我們也討論了對一些古典的認識 也討論了對現代的一些解釋系中 也涉及到孟夫、社交孟夫
我今天為什麼要再討論價值之前 說一下孟子是因為最近 孟先生和小董之間關於橫旗四季的一番討論
這個討論其實不涉及到我們什麼事情
而且我已經認為橫旗四季這樣的重要的古典文件產生巨碟的爭論
在當代產生爭論是好事
但我後來發現一個現任的問題 就是爭論的態勢 有否定小董 轉向了否定張在
橫旗四季是張在的話 就是為天地利心 為生命力 為王勝地決時 為萬世開太平
否定張在 也不是什麼了不起的事
誰都可以拿出來批評 張在也不例外
但是 你至少知道張在是誰 張在為什麼說橫旗四季
批刀大還沒有停下來開始批 很孟 批如家一路上批
我就覺得 我要長孕子了 我有點說不住了 那麼我今天花幾分鐘 聊一聊橫旗四季
這算是我比較趕快吧 另外我覺得這橫旗四季還是有必要說一下子的
因為這四季 花在我國 即是分子 心中的位置是非常高的
張在 就是距離我們已經有一千年了 就是他是公園千年前後的人了
是被送中期的一個重要的思想家
我對張在的評價 提高 提高 而提高 雖然是他引發了送名理學
我對旅時又只有批評太多 在批評方面有時候跟現在批
這個如學和批送名理學的人有相同之處
但我對張在西人 西蘇 西斯 評價提高
張在 他是一個很神奇的人 就是他在研究 佛學到學和如家
給三個學問上 在被送的他的時代應該是天花版
他的尊重的人 或者是他以老師相稱的人是泛中岩
而又有一個在向他 把他當成老師的那個人叫我而使 他加在被送自己重要的兩個改革家
也是兩個未大的在向 中間 三中岩和王岸時 兩個人都學問了得 都學問了得
但張在 應不再提下 被送是什麼情況嗎
是五代時果之後 更多的戰亂之後 進入到被送
隨著皇朝在堂木殺進攻進骨 殺進長安機 就是满機便是攻進骨
就是他把中國在堂之前形成的世足財富的這一套體系
徹底從肉體上消滅了 就是所有的貴族 他都要殺 在家上外服的入侵整個都是满了套了
所以送這一套已經不再是漢堂的社會結構了 他開始出現變化
由於送桃 它不是平民喜意 它也不是一般的改朝患代 它是皇朝冰變 它是這個
由一個貴族 它就是造假 多久王位 它還是屬於貴族 建月這樣一個結構
所以他們的整個的體系整個的統治階層的立場 缺少漢堂的體下 介紹漢堂的體下不可能有關路歸子
所以送的社會結構非常糟糕 就是比漢堂都要糟很多
炒中文法領利 地方土豪略身 如果獨水虎 大體上表達的是貴族的中期的那麼一個情況
可以說正處在內遊外患的最困難的時候 張百作為貴族天化版體的獨輸人只是分子
它在這個時候 開始副口 符合改變被送 當然了 它以老實的成為的善動宴的改革
所以習民心正失敗了 而王安時的改革他又不認同 除了一個非常困難的事
然後他開始用心去做學問 送作學問有一個非常重要的特徵 就是他們的北送的學者 移度推出帽子
要知道 什麼叫据學 為網上的据學 据學就是据獲得的學問 就是沒了 斷絕了
從誰那斷絕呢 送人人為從梦子那 控梦知道就斷了
虧說後面 形式皇分數恆如恆類似 虧說後面 上不遞 霸出百家獨自如輸 尊類似 恆得和尊得都已經不是真正的如家了
所以到了張宅的一代 他們開始孫孟為什麼孫孟呢 用我的話來說其實張宅認識到了 只有社會主義能夠救大分
所以他想將孟子的思想整理出來形成一套體系
但是他怎樣來做這件事呢 他是借剪了佛家道家的東西 所以他提出了一整套的理學的觀念叫關學
然後形成一套體系很多人並不理解理學 其實理學從張宅這個角度出發 包括用成的理解 包括五層
第一層是天理也是理學的根本所在天理 所以他為天地理系 天理之後 認識天理之後是什麼理 是血理
所以他提出戲緣的起床 血理之後是倫理 這才到了我們一般人理解送名理學的那個理 是倫理
倫理之後是法理 法理之後是治理無理 照符 就是照框印的敵代在上
所以一般不倫理 直天下講的是倫理中 表述的倫理作為大送的法理
大送律的法理 就是這麼的意義
顯然在張宅的著作中 我們能感受到張宅是一圖用梦子的主要思想 來替代當時社會流行的佛教和道教的
一些觀點 利什麼 佛教道教在堂之後會成為社會的主體意識
因為佛教的包括五代十國等等 亂成一國州 而送出他們將佛教道教作為一種
工具所謂一種 麻醉或是解決老百姓困苦的工具
而張宅 塔蘭川不是這樣想的 所以我聽了朋友發給我關於
橫旗四句 張宅的住的地方是善 善息的橫旗 所以也叫張橫旗 這四句話就被定義為橫旗四句
他們完全理解錯了張宅 完全理解不能正確的理解橫旗四句
就像是經營人無法理解梦子 我說梦子是古點社會主義者 大家真大眼睛
啊 是的 你如果看所有的介紹梦子 那個介紹都不準確的 孔子和梦子
所以說是合成為孔夢知道 他們俩也不一樣 不一樣 有相同處
這樣 我先解釋一下橫旗四句 然後再說張宅
橫旗四句的第一句是為天地地心
所以好多人說你是誰 他說為天地地心的古語是誰 誰為天地地心
你當你是誰 你還要為天地地心 底和地 你是上地嗎 第二個
大家一定不要合為心 因為張宅送朝所說的這個心
以至於明朝楊明星學所說的那個心 不是那個你理解的生物學上的那顆心
他甚至不簡簡單單是陳述一個觀點 一種意識
而他陳述的 娛樂是無理的綜合好 為天地地心
我翻譯張宅為天地地心所說的話 就兩個字了 求證
為天地地心是追求真理 是追求受發展的本質於一般性規律
這個就叫為天地地心 是求真 不是他上地牙給天地之間的一顆心
天地不需要有一顆心 但是天地在自然明明中有他運行的
羅舉歸律 否則你怎麼會來立法呢 確實有他事務發展的本質於一般歸律
對此的認識 張宅在送朝 在北送的時期打到了極高的高度
戲園理論 他即使可以物理化的 他也可以精神化的
我們今天不講張宅的戲園理論 這個但是對北送對自然的認識
達到張宅的這張水平是我感到震驚的 就是他對整理的追求和認識
不但是遠超同內人 即便是在中國5千年歷史上也有50個天娃板
我簡單說一下就是內天地地心 你就知道是兩個字修正
為生命利命 這個大家又說 這話太大了 你是誰 你為什麼可以為生命利命
利命他們不知道送到中央老百姓的生存狀況
送社會結構比漢堂差亂了 被送中斷土地監病嚴重了
三分之一的子弓弓破產 輪為農物 不是你別的電農
是輪為加農農物 為生命利命 在這裡面我想說 我的解釋就兩個字 解放
好多人問 你有什麼資格給老百姓避命
好吧 我告訴你 死人 死人 本可以雷觀要知道
她的兩個最好的朋友 前一個是飯農典 宰向後一個是王安時都想請她出山的
她一直是關 最後死在刺關的路上 她不願意做
你說她是沒錢的人嗎 當然不是啊
她家裡約有六百五十五 兩天在橫區立立法 但死人怎樣為生命利命呢
她將六百五十五 兩天一目不剩 全部分配給當時的災民流明
她給災民流明 把這個錢給她們讓她們安生利命
一個輸生的 她沒有指示說 她在做 什麼叫你有什麼資格利命
你有什麼資格利命 你點知道她是誰 她做了什麼
不要認為這是中國古人 喜歡說打話 這話可不大
但不好做啊 第三句話 未往生地局
我剛才說了 決水送的只是份子認為到孟祖 儒家的正統學文就終結了
加上行坑漢字 一大堆折腾以後的儲血剩餓了 所以大家認為孟祖刺觸 決要重新結許她
結許她的目的是什麼 你要是想為天地立現在生命利命 你需要有一套理論體系
一整套的思想 作為立法的指導啊 泛中間為什麼改革失敗
王安時為什麼改革失敗 她缺乏一套體系啊 一個被現代化了的思想體系啊
從哪找 決水 王聖是誰是空主 決水是誰是孟祖 為王聖地決決
她是想重新舉起古點社會主義 這邊大齊 為老百姓求得解放
讓承認在福京道京裡面的知識分組 回到現實中來追求真理 有些人說是如家擔務了中國的現代文明
你們真的看到張宅在幹什麼嗎 為王聖地決血 她是想高职社會主義大齊
一組 我剛才說了 只是有社會主義能夠救大宗 以後我們講價值論的時候我再次重複 只有社會主義能夠救 美麗街
最後一句話 美萬是開太平
好多人說 話太大了 萬是開太平 我知道不是用很大的功夫 你很難理解過文的 何為平
當然是何為平 公平 平等平安 何為太長久的嘛
如何來 為何談起太平 因為不太平啊 她沒有說 為萬是說太平啊 這樣太平啊
她說 開 請注意 這個不開這是張宅第一次談實劍理性啊 我們一直在說恐慌恐慌 毛澤東為什麼批評如家
就是如家 為萬是這樣太平啊 到了孟主
但孟主沒有能夠 在實劍中落實
她說 開太平意思是必須實踐 必須將這個理想 高居社會主義 其實將這個理想落實到制度和政策當中去
這個開太平 六百年之後 影響了水 王央明 王央明說了兩句話
你一句話叫治良之 一句話叫知行可以 將這兩句話我讀的時候我就知道陽明先生可能陽明先生作為偉大的政治家有些話不便講透啊
治良之 後面可以加兩個後對呀 治良之於實劍 治良之於天下 為萬是太太平 就是治良之於天下
是治行可以讓你用實劍理性來落實你的偉大的社會主義理想 陽明先生走了以後四百年之後
無難除了某人之 終於完成了實劍理性 每一萬是太太平 她治良之於天下
治良之於實劍 治良之於天下 毛澤東對張宅的評價及高啊 毛澤東在抗議員潮的時候說過一段話
美國人剛多氣勢 據遠軍 剛少起多毛澤東辭出的氣 就是張宅的氣緣理論的氣
不是你理解的那個靠氣的氣氣的氣 它是一種精神狀態
我們的剛很少到我們的氣很多 它說的是一種什麼樣的精神狀態 就是氣緣理論的一邊
關於學習的人要談的東西 王陽明他們懂了 毛澤東懂了 他們是用這樣的東西
在沒有物質條件的基礎上用氣 完成了張河 力量的張河 戰勝了 未外不可戰勝的敵人
有人說 我們不需要你為天地地心 天地自然有心 你別折躺 小明就會很幸福
請問 每三分之一輪為濃濃的人 天地管嗎? 為生命地命
說你不用力命 每個人有他自由 他只要自由發展他就會很好
請問 三分之一輪為濃濃的命 市場能管嗎?
為妄勝進居居居居居居居 沒用嗎? 送 送 開始排除孟子
重點那個人就是張宅 後面所有的孟子都推出孟子
你至於到了原朝 追分孟子為亞盛 孟子入妙 市盟國人做的分為亞盛
同時 孟國人協題 將孟子帶往歐洲形成了恋夫心和宗教改革
他們老需要我拿證據 我就是跟這個文學十分理性在討論的時候
我還在說 蘇聯文學裡面讓我看到了一些孟子的影子 就是斯拉夫夫
我將他有控我會講 最常的孤戰爭之後 導致斯拉夫夫的據點 導致歐洲的局面 但今天我們就了解了比較長了
把今天特朵快流面流 好吧
我在說的是什麼 我在說 我們今天的人在當下的原因 西方的語言 想第一節
我們的古人 理解我們的古點文學 古點的私家 遇到了巨大的障礙
有些人是故意的 想用心自由主義 因為他們反對 如家提出的天下觀大一同
尤其是反對孟子的林鄧主義 普蘇的社主義 邏輯 他們通通反對 通通反對
但請你們知道一個 這是一個自然邏輯的就是 如沒有這一套的思想提醒
中國早就決了 四分五年滅亡了 跟歐洲今天的狀況是一樣的
就是所以沒有就是因為我們數不上 有亡盛有覺覺 它在利待知識分子之中生生不習
大堂有一個人 推荐孟子 它叫韓欲 送朝一個人 推荐孟子 它叫杠在
今天我就不解釋 毛澤東最如家的屁肠 這兩天這些人 屁肠的事情主要是用教人的話來聽
他們只是也不理解教人
教人屁如家屁的事有道理的
我想教人在十七歲之前 教他似乎五斤的原道胡子 應該也給他講過孟子
也給他講過征用的 毛澤東在文章裡邊經常會用一些點
其中對如家的一些批評也是中肯的 比如說如家沒有對大的政治家
中國歷史上的大政治家都是法家 如家沒有
等等吧 當然我不同意了 你能說謠順於不是為他的政治家嗎
你能說周恩王 周五王不是為他政治家嗎 給我點教信啊 但如學 落地能夠真正的落地的人
死死 死毛 測通 再說一來一死 好吧
我今天的客視講 價值論 客補 我不能把這事都放在橫旗四句上
我們現在回到今天的主題 價值回歸於君族回歸
為什麼要講價值回歸 君族回歸呢
因為現在這個極點就是2025年的下半年可能就開始了
會在2025年下半年完成 價值回歸和君族回歸嘛
我覺得可能沒那麼快 但我個人認為 因為在2027年之前 接觸完成全球的重要資產重要商品的價值回歸
而且它是一個君族回歸的歷史過程
我覺得我講下的 因為這件事情其實是非常重要的
因為你如果不知道它在說什麼的話 可能做投資的時候會忙碌
好 我們從案例入手再回到你的
我跟香港的朋友說 也是上個星期的事了
這個小朋友們請我吃飯
他們在討論香港的房價問題
我說請準確描述香港房價下跌的幅度
他們說按照中原技術 約約10%的30% 因為是29.8% 約約10%的30%
然後他們說路先生 你難道是沒這個指出是破的
或者是你的提感不是
我其實差不多很久 因為我其實不是很願意
講這件事情 因為講這件事情會很多人會很痛啊 很痛
我在2019年第一次談斷補場景
2020年是非常正式和認真的 就是在疫情的時候
非常正式的認真的
討論這個問題 到我們將資本的和同論的時候
這個東西已經形成體系了
但你知道香港的好多朋友抱怨我就是說
你這幅的幅度就了很多人
但我們當時不知道你在說什麼
你沒有給五年以後的算答 就是五年以後
你這幅度是意味的什麼 沒告訴我
所以呢 可將來結問題
把他就是約是聰明的集結問題 約是反而是
信我而不討論的人做對話
好 回到例子 香港的房價低了多少
沒錯 中原指數是30%
那麼就是爹息了30%
但是2019年到2025年
金子黃金上漲幅度超過50%
好吧 我們就算50%
那麼 勝利的70%在減掉50%
以黃金地價 香港的房產已然跌去
6% 只剩下30%
重複
如你否在地區在內地
房價下跌30% 勝於70%
在缺去70%之百分之五十
結論時你黃金地價 以房子
已經跌去60%
如你沒有買房子 可是只有黃金
你現在約對可以買原來房子的
約對約是可以買原來的房子的
很一公尺的 接近三套 百分之三十五
這是一個殘酷的問題 我知道對有多殘酷
我為什麼對價值論對資本的第一居然如此的關注
你對價值的判斷除了問題
因為你老子里想的是每人港幣和人比
你並不知道很良一個資產
或者是一件商品或者是勞動的實度
聽我的課的人有些人聽的時間超過五年吧
他就知道我在說什麼
因為我一直在好討論資本的第一居然 討論價值論在討論價值之度
以黃金定價最什麼這麼重要
就是說我們今天要說的價值回歸 君之回歸
價值回歸給人君之回歸 君之是什麼意思
我們說的君之回歸是想大力是多其中的平均值
你說一百年補變 我想告訴你 千年補變
比如說一套房子 一千年前 可能就是兩根金條
而金錢 一顆房金 一千塊錢 一千顆房金 一公信兩根金條
一金一根 兩根金條 一百萬 二三線的房房價
所以按照君之回歸的邏輯 你覺得房金是歸了呢還是便宜了呢
是你對房對資產商品和勞動的理解 除了查作呢
還是認知問題呢 還是市場公司的問題還是交易結果呢
所以我們今天想把價值論裡面
這個部分拿出來說兩句 我知道非常震撼 我也知道
會令好多人感到 不是感到難受
但確實是平台上很多朋友 按短股長今的邏輯做了
他們可能是在用自己的時間來理解馬克思的價值來理解
或者是來實踐如何來看待 認識我們今天的市場
或是看待 我們未來可能出現的歷史歧史
處理類似於符達的問題 確實需要折血高度和歷史中身
因為如果你簡單地講一個公式 簡單地去講一個東西
往往會無感 你知道五年時間非常短暫
五年時間非常短暫
如至我們一九年開始說這件事 兩天年吧
到二零零五年 就是五年時間
五年時間 整個的市場價格出現了
超越百分之六十五的劇力等等 以皇帝立家
正確的投資選擇 將會給你帶來完全不同的結果
它確實是會影響你的人生的
我們很相信專業人士 相信機構分析師
但在香港只有五十百分之百錯
好多三港的貨金融的朋友對我有一件主要是
向我講的自署太少就付得不了
沒有陳述邏輯 沒有提供算大
就是二零九年 如果告給大家 今天皇帝價格是三千五百塊錢
那麼我們就會去買 我們就不會要房子
這就是一個小朋友 女同學的對這樣的一個思維邏輯
但是事實上不可以這樣
因為當年本來我平也是付的不改革開放
當有人需要他提供邏輯 需要提供完整的也是的時候
小朋友是給了三個字 不整輪 為什麼
因為沒有辦法重新將三本字的輪 重新將通過
沒有辦法完成這樣配到
雖然這是一個比較清晰的趨勢認識
但沒有辦法完成
我們必須在整個的進程之中
對整個的認知 包括今天講的
紅級四劇的認知
要有一個足夠的哲學高度和歷史中生
你還能真正抓到事務變化的本聚與規律
好 我該數一下吧 你們準備了六月值的教掃 請教我看
只能簡單說一些藥典給大家
克伯的第一部分我是講價值的構成一評估
價值的構成一評估裡面提供是三個部分
第一個是價值的客觀結構
這個市場重要 客觀結構裡面就涉及到做的第一劇案
馬克思對價值的定義
他確實是非常儘管的 就是明節的全部勞動
明節的勞動是馬克思認為價值的一個定義
雖然這個明節的勞動
裡面具有時間長度的話 勞動小時候也有價格計算的東西在裡面
但他這是一個值學的概括
你用勞動時間就無法比較科技價和一個送完賣的勞動時間的價值上的巨大區別
但他是客觀的 這是個窟安結構的第一個部分
就是客觀結構裡面的A是人家的勞動
客觀裡面的B是吸缺信
空氣有價值
但你沒有必要去賣
因為沒有吸缺問題
很多東西怕都有吸缺信
吸缺信是客觀存在的
因為吸缺和工具在相當床的時間是不屁派的
所以吸缺信是價值的客觀結構裡的B
C是主權 主權歸屬問題
因為東西隨好 東西隨便你 東西隨有價值
跟你沒關係
這是價值的客觀結構裡面的C要素
你記錄就算了
那麼第二個部分是價值的主觀結構
這個非常重要的事情到心裡問題了
你知道多數人不知道價值的主觀結構
價值的主觀結構的A就是需求的破解信
你越破解 越級的用 它越價值
破解信是什麼意思呢
你在沙漠上 需要的那屏水可以無限貴
你在維層裡面 需要的那個面包可以無限貴
需求的破解信
並需求的難度
有可能要付出生命 有可能只想在長春悲困的時候
很多女學生為了一個滿頭 現出了自己的中真
阿哈 需求的難度
C價值吃不
價值的主觀結構裡面 非要素
需求的破解信需求的難度 價值吃不
我今天講黃金就是講
它是一個主觀結構 就是價值吃不
因為你在討論香港 房價和國內房價的時候
你用的是港幣和人民幣 具有期限性
你看不出來那個主觀結構
它不真實
如果你懂得價值的構成和它的評估的話
你分得清客觀結構和主觀結構的時候
你會避免很多的錯誤一個房子
在你的主觀結構裡面是三桶
首先它是居住 反正你的居住需求
其次可能還要滿足你的投資需求
第三個層次可能滿足你的信用心
你懂得價值的主觀結構嗎
你懂得價格主觀結構的時候
你可以完成獨立完成價值團團嗎
這裡面我有兩句話請大家記住
你一切價值都有時間 決定性就是獨棄
你一切價格都有制度和政策的規定性
一個是決定性一數 周期的決定性一個是
制度和政策的規定性
必須要明白這裡面的邏輯
在價值的構成於屏股裡面的第三個部分
是屏股或者是綜合屏股
這是一個非常難的技術
因為你得非常冷靜的提前五年完成預期
否則我剛剛說了
時間決定性你真的要懂週期
制度和政策的規定性你真的需要懂制度
除了這個東西之外在縱科屏股裡面
還有一個關於共識度的認同
就是你必須了解大眾心理
就是大眾心理這個根據論導向還是甚麼
就是在整個預期管理裡面
這個東西它有一個非常嚴重的共識度問題
就是所有的人
所有的輿論將於導入房屋是個面子
你住在哪兒別人覺得房子是非常狀的
是不是這麼良成為這個要寫的一個工具
它實際上是個共識度
就是當你被這個讀東西引導之後
你就會進入到下支判斷書
比如說數字貨幣
時間過得非常快
我們第二個部分加按一下下支規規規
這個價值規規的完整的理論概數
將來有幾乎寫給你們吧
就是甚麼價值規規
我這裡本簡單說一點
大家用著找東西
價值規規規裡面我想談一個問題
就是價格泡沫的場面和分析
為什麼因為有了價格泡沫
破滅的時候是價格規規規
低谷的時候長上去也是價格規規
那麼你幾對價格泡沫
有足夠的認識你才能理解
合為價格規規
泡沫的人其實是簡單的
一般是一種佛爵
是價值變先的歷史趨勢出現的佛爵
我就不解釋了時間不夠
第二個是人為製造的恐慌
這個恐慌包括制度性化證明的恐慌
人為製造的第三個是不可很災難
比如說散災難或者戰爭等等都會造成距離的波動
會出現地事性的低點
我今天說的這些話
不夠成你們投資依據
比如說我認為房價到2017年
可能就處理了
底部結束走出新的過程來
我為什麼有一個其實新的判斷
就是比如說
為什麼你不會被我和他講的一些制度
政策這些東西很嚴重
因為我對周期的敏感都超過了
一般人所以我才會提三、九、一百八十年周期
我在會談畢業佛週期六十年周期
周期非常重要
因為你知道大的歷史周期
根本跟人的干預沒什麼關係
大的歷史周期
透法而張轉說的那個自由道理
小的周期的歷史有時候很重大周期
沒有人沒的歷史
而我認為25年我們要經歷風息
恰恰是大歷史周期
所以我覺得今天就加下了
或者將來有時候在乎一套
我看著今天這個課
跟一百多相不了
好加著回歸裡面的另外一個問題
不講了透過的原因分析將來
第三個是下個回歸價值的方式一路進的
價格是微老的價值進行波動的
有時候高於價值有時候低價值
他回歸價值的方式
他通常會通過怎樣的方式來回歸
當價格嚴重低於價值的時候
在經歷經濟分長的周期的時候
他會開始不斷地向上長
而價格泡沫一旦聲稱
他價值會回歸的方法
就非常簡單就是經濟危機
而這個經濟危機可能會被人為的延長
就是危機的爆發被迫使
爆發的時間被拉長
我今天再講價格的時候
和價值的時候
我反覆在講別的東西
我就是不講公體於需求
因為我認為公體於需求
特別是經濟實在提供的
公體於需求的判斷
往往存在重大的問題
因為其實我個人認為
我今天講的第一步非常重要
我非常重要的是看起來
我今天講價值購成立便講了
價值的客觀購成和價值的購觀購成
我個人認為公體於需求
很大程度上是非主觀購成所謂的
所以我對公體學派的沒套東西
真的
我不能說全面否定
但是我是只有非常深刻的懷疑
因為公體學派從來就沒解決過分子
方式我就不講了
陸進太長了
我也不講了
我講一下新的回歸
真知回歸也不講了
因為我明天下午有會
我不知道能不能騰出時間
明天下午在了解局
下午市場
我這時候我我將結論的部分
第四個部分
簡單講了幾乎香港有我控制回歸所謂
將我這趟一刻背著教案在講了幾乎
我今天不該在橫岐司機上的時候
太長時間
我想講第四個問題是
死倫聯價值回歸過程中的資產與商品價格
變動的邏輯與進程
我就直接說結論
因為我們沒有時間把推倒過程說了
就是
我剛剛在安娜我所謂
好吧
我重新來
目前我們以美元計價的資產與勞動的
估值全部被嚴重高估
目前這個高估
主要不要大於美人會議
高估多少呢
我認為美國總之產的價格
應被高估
百分之兩百
美元計價的勞動價格
被高估了百分之三百
在10多年前
有一位香港的女士
名人現在很牛
他問我
他說你認為美元和人民的合理
會議是多少
我說一比三
後來他們在場很多經濟學家
還有些幾個問題是
後來成為他們在公務場
和吵吊我的一段很多人
就是那些事情說
他說一比三
事實上一比三是保守的
就是因為美元計價的資產和商品
以及勞動其實是被嚴重高估的
我剛才說了資產的
估值高估了百分之兩百左右
商品
勞動高估了百分之三百左右
回到一比三
都不是一個很正常的過程
但是確實不能回到一比三
五五的出口就出問題了
但是請注意2024年
我國的主流經濟學家和專家們
那麼多人在推我國的人民幣邊緻
他們又會說
把一會說就又會說是
現在這個情況好一點
我們今天講個當然不是提定他們的
我們是討論
價值會不易
美洋會據高估
解決的方法有兩個
一個是關稅戰通過
尤其商品價格來解決
會提問提
第二個
如果關稅戰不能正常進行
就必須地通過
便值美元來解決問題
現在看來關稅戰
出現了問題
那麼只是要第二方法
便值美元
我沒有伏考的是
美元便值的
方式和進程
方式就是
還有什麼方式來臉
進程就是時間接點
這兩個事情都集為重要
這是我們做
投資的必須考慮
方式我簡單給你們
描述一下子
是中心坦達
就是你把它想同一個圓盤
這個圓盤
這個圓盤是一個最大的挺起
美元
匯率幫它是中心坦達
中心是什麼
重新就是黃金
就是美元已經在坦達
它坦達的是中心點
更新點是黃金
它會隨著更新坦達
拉動整個資產和商品
一層一層的
往下坦達
黃金的坦達已經出現
其他坦達
結果和層次
講案
我們可以把圖
就是它一層層結果
它是一個
不是一下的整體坦達
它是中心坦達之後
就像是個聯繫的苦散
然後整個圓盤
最後全部坦達下去
完成金指揮櫃
好吧
至於其他的事情
其實我圓盤準備了
這個包括
IC-3的問題
包括美元變之後
好吧
我就
先說這麼多
我看看坦達還是在來一場客
我現在是吃兩這麼多
然後明天下午
因為幾天來不及假細節了
明下午我整體
堂多相我明下午有退
可能說晚一點吧
我整體通知時間
給大家聊幾句試堂
今天我下午還有事
所以跟大家說說
說說說這個起
因為
這個
這平台
又將這個
小豪
去年了
今天
公眾起來又有一件事情
上來
我請大家原諒
我也會開始
小心
不再說一些
沒有意義的話
請大家在聽台上發言
也誤必要
小心血
不天麻煩
其實是到了
一個非常關鍵的管制界點
我相信大家都很緊張
三官方面
以為緊張
其實我沒有服什麼
我也沒有說錯什麼
但是我知道大家
高度緊張
那就稍微放鬆一些吧
好的
祝大家多麼一塊
如有時間
明天下午見